merci et lætitia d'être avec nous dans
ce 6 à 7 regardez comme ils sont ici ont
tous les deux et installez-vous à fait
vrai que c'est assez homogène au point
un petit jeu c'est un truc de ouf enfin
franchement la dernière fois que je sais
je sais il ya là plein qui peuvent pas
monter c'est pour ça qu'ils font plus
fabien lecoeuvre le plus parce que c'est
la vie on doit installer un échafaudage
ses maladresses hell no i laetitia merci
d'être là très content que vous soyez là
jours que vous avez le sourire et ça me
fait plaisir parce que c'est ce qu'on
veut et sait ce qu'on veut vous donner
le sourire
noah il a dix ans il a atteint du
syndrome d'adams oliver alors c'est quoi
ce syndrome c'est une affection une
infection rare caractérisée par
l'association d'anomalies congénitales
des membres et d'anomalies du cuir
chevelu quand vous pouvez le voir est
souvent accompagnée de défaut de l'oci
fication du crâne
ce que noah un trou sur le sommet du
crâne qui ne cessent de s'infecter et
les hémorragies ne cesse de se répéter
c'est sa laeticia et nous aurait été et
est même franchement et je te vois je te
vois que des questions aux bras sinon
efficace
comment tu as fait un job à huawei et
qui ont taclé quoi je vais le retrouver
celui qui a fait ça a bien joué quand
même à continuer à jouer même quand tu
t'es cas c'est moi que tu l'aies tu t'en
es rendu compte qu'après où tu t'es dit
tout de suite quand il ya un problème
assez s'arrête pas là il veut pas lâcher
fois il veut pas lâcher le foot et été
franchement tu es une bombe a eu comme
ici rocheman et il est magnifique et
noah c'est un cas unique en france et
c'est le troisième dans le monde
bof on parle jamais de syfy pas lésiné
malaisie en fait il ya 150 cas dans le
monde
alors bye à 150k dans le monde et
et on n'a pas beaucoup en france jeudi
107 en france et noah est le seul cas à
son degré à lui à son âge à lui et c'est
à dire que les autres enfants à son âge
vont bien d'accord et non pas vous ne
sont pas dans son état actuel alors
l'unique opération qui pulse or ici aux
etats unis
ça coûte 350 mille euros ouais alors
vous avez fait une cagnotte pour
l'instant vous avez récolté plus de deux
cent dix mille euros pour le moment donc
si vous avez dans ces camps la cagnotte
on l'a lancé en fait on la lance un
petit peu avant d'avoir le rendez-vous
en zoom avec les chirurgiens des états
unis d'accord à ce qu'on avait un début
d'espoir on s'était dit que au cas où et
quand ils nous ont donné le feu vert qui
nous ont donné la date d'opération
saisissez votre chance et c'était le 20
avril d'accord et donc la hâte un petit
peu plus d'un mois
ouais donc et là il faut aller vite
maintenant
là il fallait vite l'opération est
prévue le 7 juillet très bien on doit
être sur place le 22 juin
ça c'est très court alors là vous avez
plus de deux cent dix mille euros qui
ont été reconnus récoltés pour le moment
pour faire un don sur le site vous
veillez à ww.carrefour.fr exact on peut
sauver nos races à celle tous ensemble
en faisant un don il ya beaucoup de
stars qui se sont mobilisés pour pour
noah nous ce soir on va on va faire un
bon déjà tout de suite et de 10000 euros
pour doit bien entendu pour passer à 200
mm
il faut rajouter on racontera ensuite
bien sûr si on n'y arrive pas
le 7 juillet ou ne tenait au courant et
on veut que nos aarau viennent à la
rentrée sur le plateau voilà et qu'il
soit heureux que vous soyez heureux il
déjà il a l'air heureux c'est ça que
j'aime et qui sont encore plus heureux
et qu'ils soient sauvés donc on va tout
faire on va tout faire pour
et j'attends de vos nouvelles à la
rentrée j'attends de vos nouvelles déjà
avant le 7 la semaine du 7 pour voir où
on en est de la cagnotte d'accord et si
voilà ici on il faut qu'on faut qu'on y
arrive on y arrive le 7 juillet c'est
notre seule chance aujourd'hui donc on
n'a vraiment pas envie de la rater il
n'en peut plus il en peut plus ça fait
dix ans que ça dure c'est les
souffrances tous les jours il
il a besoin que ça s'arrête là nora
comment tu te sens tu dois t'en veux toi
qui t'y crois là tu as envie de faire
l'opération 1
je sens qu'il ya une grosse mobilisation
autour de toi tu as envie d'aller aux
états unis cet été tu fais l'opération
après tu restes là bas tranquille ça
prend combien de pour l'opération j'ai
pas osé demander à un rocher peur en
fait de ce combat me dire si j'ai peur
qu'on me dise que ça dure plus longtemps
qu'une simple opération pourra pas vous
ainsi que des choses comme ça je ne veux
pas ça parce que vous avez des questions
prônera pour c'est vraiment brighelli
j'aurais voulu savoir si si si cette
opération elle a déjà fonctionné
si c'est ça la raison moi c'est sûr
qu'elle fonctionne alors en fait il ya
deux opérations il ya la première qui
consiste à remodeler le crâne et elles
refermées du coup et il ya la deuxième
opération et qui est une greffe de
lambeaux vivant pour pouvoir refermer la
peau ce qui n'a pas de pot non plus du
coup et ces deux opérations ont déjà été
faites sur des patients indépendamment
jamais les deux sur le même patient
d'accord et jamais sur un adams oliver
d'accord dont les chirurgiens sont très
confiants car il n'y a pas de raison que
ça marche pas et ça ne marche pas et
c'est une opération voulue très coûteuse
1 351 très très cher
cent vingt mille euros il faut
absolument arriver à avoir avant quand
la date dans le rouge et noir c'est bon
à l'avancé début juillet il est opéré le
7 juillet on doit être sur place le 22
juin à d'accord c'est vrai mais si vous
arrivez avec 200 milles et vous dites on
vous donne son bilan non mais non mais
si vous arrivez voilà en tout cas s'il
faut se dire pour début juillet j'irai
quoi il faut attendre qu'ils arrivent et
il faut se battre pour noah on va tout
faire pour que tous s'engagent et les
chroniqueurs aller poster tous les jours
toutes les semaines
la cagnotte très bien sûr le temps tout
le temps tout le temps là c'est possible
quand même donner de l'âme données même
donné quelques dollars raymond va donner
oui on a d'autres oui c'est cette
opération en france personne n'est
capable de la réaliser en france elle
n'est pas réalisable
elle n'a toujours pas été homologué en
france on espère par la suite pouvoir
justement l'un porté ici pour pouvoir
aider d'autres notre sens de notre
enfance qu'avec l'association qu'on a
créé on aide également d'autres familles
d'enfants atteints
on les aide pas le financement de
matériaux d les consultations et les
guides aussi beaucoup parce que c'est
très difficile de trouver un médecin qui
connaît cette pathologie très très peu
et du coup on espère justement pouvoir
les aider de façon médical cette fois ci
on pouvant en espérons pouvoir importer
l'opération ici il n'aurait pas arrêté
combien de temps aux états unis après
pour l'art et que le temps de
récupération alors en sortie de blocs il
doit rester minimum 10 jours hospitalisé
ensuite il va rester deux semaines au
grand minimum aux usa ce sport va
dépendre
c'est vraiment ce qu'on espère vraiment
qu'ils envoient des photos aux états
unis
inquiétez pas vous voir en tout cas
merci ce cas ci les vacheries on délivre
des reçu cerfa ça c'est important parce
que ça peut également pousser le
donateur dans sa générosité sur et c'est
important également pour le donateur de
savoir qu'elle ait reçu cerfa ça l'est
également pour les impôts les nuances
arfa s'est penché sur les coûts des
polémiques ont emballé